What I want to do in this
video is to give you the gist
of what the Roth IRA is all about.
Just to get an idea of why
it's called the Roth IRA,
it's named after William Roth,
the late senator from Delaware.
He helped, I guess,
you could say shepherd
this legislation in 1997
when it was first passed
so they named the IRA after him.
William Roth from Delaware.
That's where the word comes from.
It's a special type of
individual retirement account.
Why did they go to the
trouble of creating a new one?
Let's think about what
a traditional IRA does
and then I'll talk about why a
Roth IRA could be interesting
or it's a little bit different
or what could be beneficial
and then we'll actually
see it in an example.
The first question is what
happens when you put money
into a traditional or a Roth IRA?
In the traditional IRA video
you saw that it's tax deferred.
That if you were to put
$5,000 in your traditional IRA
you are not taxed on that money.
In the Roth IRA it is not deferred
so you would actually
pay taxes on that $5,000.
Immediately you're saying,"Hey gee.
"This doesn't seem like
that great of a thing.
"Why would I ever use it?
"I have to pay taxes on
the money I've put in."
This is the interesting thing.
In both situations, as long
as your investments stay in
either traditional or Roth accounts
earnings are not taxed while in account.
This is true for both of them.
But you're still going to say, "Hey Sal.
"The traditional still looks a lot better.
"I had to pay taxes on the
Roth right from the get-go.
"I didn't have to pay
it on the traditional.
"Then they can both grow
"and I can buy and sell my stocks
"or invest in mutual funds
"or whatever I do inside of them.
"I don't pay taxes.
"The traditional still looks better."
Now, the interesting thing is what happens
when you withdraw the money?
There's a lot of special circumstances
on when a withdrawal is qualified or not.
I'm not going to know the details
I really just want to give you the essence
of why the Roth is interesting.
Let's say you're over 59-1/2 years old
and in the Roth.
Your money has been there
for more than 5 years,
it's been seasoned.
I'm not going to go into
all of the particulars.
The traditional IRA when you withdraw,
let's say we're older than 59-1/2 for both
and then we do a withdrawal.
In the traditional IRA
you have to pay taxes.
You pay taxes, you're taxed.
Ordinary income tax.
While in the Roth IRA no taxes. Not taxed.
We saw in the traditional IRA video
that this has to be pretty good
when you're older than 59-1/2.
You might be retired.
You might be in a lower tax bracket.
You're going to pay lower taxes on it
and it's been deferred
for however many years
your IRA has been in existence.
This is especially interesting
because over here you paid tax
just on the original
amount that you've put in
and then you'll allow that
original amount to grow
over many, many, many years
and then all of a sudden
you're not taxed at all.
That, all of a sudden, becomes
a little bit interesting.
This seems like a pretty
good thing to have.
We're going to actually
play with the numbers
to see how they workout.
Now, the other interesting
thing about the Roth
is if you early withdrawal.
For a traditional IRA you pay 10% penalty
on the withdrawal plus you get taxed.
Plus taxes.
On the Roth IRA if you're just
taking the original amount
you've put in
and I'll do this with a numerical example.
If you're just taking
out your principal amount
no taxes or penalty on the principal.
No taxes or penalty on principal.
And you would only have to pay
even if it's a non-qualified withdrawal.
There's all these special
circumstances, what's qualified
and I'm not going to go to the details.
You would only have to pay the 10% penalty
and taxes on earnings.
One of the main reasons
why I'm not going in
all the details is one:
It would make the video
a little confusing,
but also, the government
is constantly changing
the details.
I want you to be able to watch this video
as many years in the
future and not to be dated
so I don't want to go into
all of the different things
that the government is
changing from year to year.
Let's just do a very basic example
just to get the sense of things.
Let's look at at a traditional IRA
and then we have a Roth.
Let me write IRA just to be clear
that we're talking about an
IRA in both circumstances.
Let's say my original income amount,
let's say I've made more than $5,000.
I'll just use $5,000 as my example
and I'll also make another note.
Roth IRA is subject to more limitations
in terms of your total overall income
and that's also changing.
I don't want to be
specific on the numbers.
You could look that up.
There are ways that you can
transfer traditional IRAs
into Roth IRAs.
That's a little bit of a loophole
on being able to get around
some of those restrictions.
But anyway, I won't go
into the details just yet.
Just remember, Roth IRA,
there are some more limitations
on whether or not you
can put things into it.
If you're tricky you might
be able to get around them.
Let's say you have $5,000.
And just so you know, the limits on IRA
is they apply to Roth or traditional
or any combination of the two.
If you're starting with $5,000,
so in the traditional IRA
you have 0 taxes initially.
In your Roth IRA initially,
let's say you have a 32% tax bracket
just like in the previous video.
32% of tax bracket.
Then you'll pay 32% on
$5,000, 32% on $5,000.
That's .32 x $5,000. That's $1,600.
You're going to pay $1,600 in taxes.
Your amount in the account,
in your account, your principal,
in your traditional IRA
and maybe I should write it out here.
Starting with that $5,000 your principal
is going to be $5,000 here.
You have to take 1,600 out for taxes
so it's only going to
be $3,400 right there.
Let's say in either situation
you were to take that,
invest it in some stocks
and then 5 years later it doubles.
Let's say at some future point it doubles
and you sell those stocks.
That becomes $10,000 in your account there
and then this, you invest
it in stocks and it doubles.
This becomes $7,800 in
your account right here.
This is 5 years into the future.
I'm just picking that into the future.
Let's say we're still not
59-1/2 years old just yet.
Now, we could just continue to leave
either of these amounts in our account
until we're 59-1/2.
Let's say we have some type of need,
we need to give a loan to our
brother-in-law or something.
We really want to have
access to this money.
Let's look at the situation
where we withdraw.
If we were to withdraw,
let's think of a couple of situations.
If we were to withdraw $3,400.
Let's say that exactly what
my brother-in-law needs
just right now.
If we were to withdraw $3,400
in the traditional IRA sense,
in the traditional IRA case.
We take out $3,400. We're
going to have to do 2 things:
First, we're going to
have to pay taxes on it.
We're going to have to pay 32% of that
assuming we're still in
the same tax bracket.
$3,400 x .32 is equal to,
we're going to have pay $1,088 in taxes.
We're going to have to
pay $1,088 in taxes.
We're also going to have to pay a penalty
on this entire amount, on the $3,400.
We're also going to
have to pay 10% penalty,
$340 penalty.
We're going to be left with
after paying all of these,
let me get the calculator
out and let's see,
the calculator right there.
We're going to be left with
3,400 - 1,088 - $340 = $1,972.
We're left with $1,972.
In the Roth IRA,
when you needed that money all of a sudden
and you decided to withdraw it early
and we're only taking out $3,400.
We're taking the amount that
was our original principal.
In the Roth IRA we get the $3,400
because that was our original amount
and we pay no taxes or penalties.
At any point in time on the Roth IRA
you can always take your principal out.
In the other types of IRAs
not only will you have to pay taxes on it,
you're also going to have to
pay a penalty on top of that.
The Roth IRA, one of
the very positive things
is it gives you a lot of flexibility.
Now, let's say you needed
to withdraw, I don't know,
let's say you needed to withdraw $4,000.
This is another scenario, $4,000
at this same point in time.
Within the traditional IRA scenario,
once again, you're
going to have to pay 32%
of that in taxes. You're
going to have to pay
4,000 x 32% in taxes
and you're also going to have to pay
+ $400 penalty.
In the Roth IRA case, you pay nothing.
You get the original
principal you have put in,
that was your original amount, $3,400.
In all of this, I'm assuming
that we're not 59-1/2 years old just yet.
In the Roth situation,
you get the $3,400 free and
clear, tax and penalty free.
But the other $600, you're
going to have to pay 32% taxes
or whatever your tax bracket is
and then you're also
going to have to pay $60,
a 10% penalty on just
the earnings portion.
Remember, 3,400 was your principal,
then if you want to take
4,000 out, the 600 extra,
that stuff that you earned.
That stuff that was
grown from the principal.
You're going to have to pay
plus another $60 penalty.
But it's still a much better
situation if you do the math
than this one here.
In general, if you
think, if you're not sure
whether you're going to need that money
before you retire,
the Roth gives you a lot more flexibility.
Now, let's go all the way to retirement.
Let's go all the way to retirement.
Let's say we didn't
ever withdrew any money.
We invest it in another stock
and so we go 10 years later.
We never withdrew any money.
We're just going to look at
the retirement situation.
We go to our stock and we
sell it, our new stock.
We get the 20,00 there,
here we get $15,600.
Of course, in both of these situations
its great that we're able
to buy and sell stocks
inside of these retirement accounts
and not pay taxes.
If these were not sitting
in retirement accounts
every time we bought and sold the stocks
we would have to pay capital gains tax
and you saw that in the previous video.
Now, now that we are over,
let's say we're 60 years old.
We can now withdraw our
money from either situation.
There's some other stipulations,
your money has to be seized
and has to be sitting
there for 5 years and all
but I won't go into the details.
Let's see what happens
when we withdraw the money.
Let's say we have a 25% tax bracket now.
25% tax bracket.
We're retiree, we're earning
a little bit less money,
we are in a lower tax bracket.
In this situation we're going to pay,
when we withdraw it from a traditional IRA
we are going to pay 25% in
taxes which is $5,000 in taxes
and we are going to be left
with $15,000 for ourselves
to spend in our retirement years.
In the Roth IRA situation,
once we're over 60 years
old our tax bracket
doesn't matter.
We just get the money,
$15,600 free and clear.
If you think about it in either situation,
when we withdrew early,
the Roth IRA was much more forgiving
especially if we withdraw
less than the amount
that we originally put in, $3,400.
The Roth IRA does not tax us
or give us penalties.
It only does that on any
money that we earned,
any money in excess of the $3,400.
The traditional IRA
taxes us and penalizes us
on everything.
Even when we go into the future, remember,
in the traditional IRA
we didn't pay any taxes to begin with
but we had to pay taxes to end with.
When we paid taxes in the end,
we're paying taxes not just
on what we've put in initially
we're also paying taxes on all of
our cumulative earnings, right?
We originally put in 5,000,
now we're paying taxes on 20,000.
We're going to only end up with $15,000
while in the Roth IRA we
don't pay taxes on anything.
In return for being willing
to pay our taxes front loaded
to pay them in the beginning,
we'll never have to
pay taxes on that money
or on any of the earnings
that that money makes.
Now, I fixed the numbers
here to make them close.
Depending on your tax
bracket before and after
or how much growth you
actually see in your earnings,
one maybe better than the other.
But these are important considerations.
I just want to let you
know the pros and cons.
The Roth IRA tends to be better
in terms of giving you this flexibility
and not worrying to pay taxes at the end.
There's one other thing,
this is depending on how you view life,
it might be a minor thing.
In the traditional IRA, when you're 70-1/2
they force withdrawal
and then of course you have to
start paying taxes on things.
In a Roth IRA, there's no age limit.
That's another consideration
you might want to take into.